make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
you know just for my own personal
enjoyment i have re-cut the trailer
for avengers in game change the music
and everything and i think it's better
than any of the trailers they originally
released i love it i absolutely love it
obviously i can't post it up anywhere on
youtube because of copyright problems
but
uh i enjoyed i promise i actually did it
i feel like some of you guys this is
like the the comics explained trailer
version of like tribute
you know like it's the best it's not the
best song in the world it's just a
tribute to the best song in the world
which i played you have to believe me
like
[Laughter]
but i actually did it maybe i'll post it
on vimeo or something like that let me
know down in the comment section if you
guys want to see it but
uh but we're picking up with future
state this is what's kind of cool about
this uh by the way
uh in the last video the one that i did
about the next batman i kept saying luke
fox uh for some reason i kept thinking
whenever i read about it online
they said luke fox was gonna be the new
batman apparently it's his brother tim
fox a newly introduced character so
thank you guys for that correction i
know you guys don't shy away from being
like
actually rob you're incorrect the
correct thing
is tim fox like i know you guys are are
huge
on making sure that that i have factual
information because i'm only human
i mess up but uh but thank you you know
thank you for that that correction so i
will get it right going forward
i'm not really sure if it picks up
before i assume it picks up before the
events of
um of what's going on with tim fox and
batman and it would be cool if it did
that it was kind of like the events
leading up to batman comics or maybe it
takes place at the same time
we're not really given a definitive
answer here but if they do take place at
the same time it's kind of awesome but
what this does here is initially picks
up in the city of gotham
and that gotham as it's kind of
described here is like a city that's
basically dying now it's not that zoe
gotham is dying in a literal sense like
the economy tanked
everybody's moving out it's not like it
became detroit right that's not really
what we're talking about here
what we're talking about here is gotham
as it was known
basically dying off so the the city
where it essentially people basically
had some measure of freedom different
things like that
and the reason why is because it's it's
kind of given to us as very much the
sort of totalitarian city that's ruled
with an iron fist
now the the first the person giving us
this perspective
is bruce wayne himself and it kind of
bounces back and forth a smidge in the
sense that you've got bruce wayne who
more or less seems to be a cast off in
the city of gotham and the reason why is
because he was shot in a dark alley
somewhere
right and and seemingly the reason why
he was shot in a dark alley is that at
some point
on the line as we'd covered in the
batman comics assuming the two go hand
in hand
that once you started seeing the rise of
these kind of totalitarian police
led by what was essentially the
magistrate or the ruler of gotham
uh that bruce wayne has kind of been on
the fly now we know that individuals
just from the batman comic we know the
individuals who wear masks are basically
outlawed right anybody who wears a mask
is considered to be an
outlaw in the city of gotham and so we
can largely assume that as soon as this
was passed batman was public enemy
number one
and even in so far as the batman comic
itself with tim fox he refers to himself
as public enemy number one right so we
can largely assume that the exact same
thing happened to bruce wayne here when
it all kicked off but you know the
the important point here is it looks
like one of these guys are the ones who
shot bruce wayne and so kind of focusing
on the moment now he's just
essentially kind of making his way
around the city of gotham
uh without you know trying not to get
caught and he's completely and totally
broke right he doesn't have
anything one because of the fact that
bruce wayne is believed to have been
dead right so
how can a dead man you know use a bank
account doesn't really work that way i
mean
i guess you could but for the the
intentions of this video or this this
comic he can't
and he's not like an average joe out
there right somebody whose identity was
stolen like he saw the identity of a
dead man
and he's kind of been walking around
ever since it's bruce wayne right it's
like like they said in batman begins
he's the prince of gotham you have to
drive two thousand miles to find someone
who doesn't know his name right so i
mean because of that he can't just walk
around and pretend to be alive right so
he has basically
nothing on him whatsoever more so than
that he's actually kind of having this
this bit of a conversation it's kind of
one-sided but a bit of a conversation
with a girl this at this restaurant that
he's eating at right this place
you know spending what little money has
left if any money at all and she's kind
of talking about the the nature of these
things right you know that
that batman's gone the batman's
basically out of commission right bruce
wayne's dead that both of them believe
are believed to have been dead right
because people don't know that bruce
wayne and batman are the same person so
batman's dead bruce wayne's dead and she
kind of makes this
this interesting observation here where
she says you know it's kind of crazy
like maybe bruce wayne offed himself
because he lost all of his money or
maybe it could be drugs right but
surely somebody like bruce wayne could
could find a way to get his hands on
drugs and i know it seems kind of
throwaway and it doesn't really seem
relevant but this kind of gives us a
good depiction of how the people of
gotham
see bruce wayne is that that in reality
despite all the things that the wayne
foundation has done
the the measurement or the i guess the
litmus test by which we as people
determine whether or not our lives are
getting better is usually by how much
money we have in our wallet right that's
usually what we do
that's how we as people function do i
have more money in my wallet now
than i did yesterday yesterday being a
metaphor for like the year before or
four years before or something like that
i mean that's how reagan beat jimmy
carter he asked the american people is
your life better than it was four years
ago right
it's that kind of situation and so as
long as we are as long as we we're
financially better off
as long as we're able to pay our bills
and our life feels like it's better than
for the most part
things are okay the world could be
burning down around us but as long as we
feel like things are getting better then
that's all that matters right that's the
price you pay for society governed by
its feelings but the important thing
here is that people view bruce wayne as
kind of this perception of
this guy out there in in gotham
somewhere this super rich guy
the cream of the crop the very very top
uh and what does he really care about
the average joe right what do you really
care about the average person i'm sure
he's done some philanthropy different
things like that but if you're a person
barely making ends meet and you're not
seeing your paycheck getting any bigger
or you're not seeing your rent get any
cheaper then the question is what does
bruce wayne do for you right
that's the kind of situation you run
into people kind of looking at their
lives in a microchasm and not really
looking at the bigger picture which
admittedly is kind of difficult to do
when you're struggling but
at the end of the day of what use is a
society whose individuals cannot see
themselves as part of a greater whole
right at that point that society is just
doomed to failure and so in the
aftermath of bruce wayne being shot he
of course ends up taking residence at a
kind of a backdoor surgeon right and
it's just kind of like i can pay right
you know i can pay
and the reality is that this is the last
of the money that he has right so
seemingly before he got to this
restaurant
he has no money whatsoever right the
last money he spent the last
few dollars in his pocket were to have
surgery done in order to get himself
better you know in order to heal himself
to a degree you know so you can recover
because there's nowhere for him to go
right all of his money's been taken we
don't really know how he got to this
point we don't really know how we got to
this place from
you know bruce wayne as as batman and
operating in the city of gotham and
doing his thing to this point right now
it could be that dc may very well
wrap back around to the events of batman
comics that are not part of future state
where you have like ghost maker and all
that kind of stuff and the actions of
batman and ghost maker working together
lead to this we don't really know right
i mean it's one of these things where
this is just a potential future that
exists in dc
coming out of the events of death metal
right so who knows that this will
actually be in continuity or not but
more so than that you basically end up
having peacemaker number one right kind
of uh
uh you know the head of the of this you
know totalitarian police force
essentially and it's one of the things
where they basically talk about this
idea of splitting the difference right
they basically say okay
you know what we have here on one side
is we have vigilantes on the other side
we have criminals and what's the
difference between batman and a criminal
well batman hands criminals over to the
cops but it's one of these things where
it's kind of like at the end of the day
more often than not we can't really tell
the difference now make no mistake here
this is not making an argument like the
one that i make you can't make an ammo
without breaking a few eggs right if
batman really wants to make gotham safer
you take inventory of the villains who
just refuse to or cannot be redeemed you
kill him off and everybody else you just
toss them to the cops
uh this is one of those things where
this is vying for power and this is
usually how you see this kind of thing
unfold now again we don't know the
nuance of this but we could go so far as
to say that a lot of it really seems to
be some kind of an underground movement
or something along those lines something
akin to like the tv show jericho from
2006
or like the handmaid's tale if you guys
never saw those they're amazing right
they're absolutely amazing uh it's one
of these things where to a degree
the people of gotham kind of seem to be
on board with this not in the sense of
like i mean they're a little weary like
what could this lead to right but it's
one of these things where by the time
you realize something's wrong it's too
late for you to stop it right
and that's sort of what's going on here
to a degree these this magistrate and
these these peacemakers have basically
taken control of gotham right they they
have the whole thing
under their control now we're not really
given this depiction that life is
terrible for people in gotham and that's
usually how dictatorships people like
that
maintain control they keep life good for
the people who are there
right i mean you would be far less apt
to support a dictatorship that had you
living in concentration camps and
you know if in comparison to a
dictatorship then had you living like a
better life than you are right now i
mean sure some of your freedoms would be
taken away but at the end of the day you
know you
you probably find a way to make those
concessions you probably find a way to
to accept that and we know that because
we've seen that happen throughout the
world
time and time again never happened here
in the states but it probably will like
i mean
it has to be some kind of fool to
believe that the us will not experience
some sort of authoritarian or
dictatorship
in like the next 50 years right you'd
have to be a fool to believe that
wouldn't happen
but gotham as it's shown here is far
more advanced than it was right so
it's kind of intriguing because bruce
wayne's not that old and so it's kind of
like okay i mean right it's not like you
know batman beyond where ruth bruce
wayne's like 70 or 80 years old or
something like that he's all grizzled
he's just
it's not like that but he's he was a
lovable dick like we loved bruce wayne
and batman beyond he was amazing
just this crotchety old man who was just
mean you know it was it was
funny right it was just it was funny but
like he's still relatively young here
right so again this is one of those
things a future possibility you know so
it probably doesn't come out of the
existing batman comics that are not part
of a future state with like you know
ghost maker and all that kind of stuff
and and somewhere along the line you
know it seems at least from what we're
told somewhere on the line batman or
bruce wayne seem to get in bed with what
was effectively this magistrate type
character right where he makes his way
back into the city of gotham he's kind
of walking around trying to stay hidden
at the same time that in the aftermath
of what was believed to have been his
death that like there was this great big
huge
kind of mourning period and this face
was all over these giant billboards and
all that kind of stuff but gotham looks
very much like what
you would expect a futuristic new york
state to look right it's like a
neo-gotham
more or less it's kind of how you would
expect it to look where it's like highly
advanced super
you know all kinds of technology
different things like that so it kind of
makes you wonder
exactly how things unfolded in this
place again it's a possible future but
not a guaranteed future but if it is a
future that means that it's currently
tied to the present and the question you
have to ask is if batman looks like he's
at most
five to ten years older than what kind
of technological revolution the gotham
experience because hell's bells
that place looks totally different
[Laughter]
it looks kind of nuts but ultimately
it's one of these things where in the
aftermath of the fact that he's more or
less been outlawed he lost
everything right he's believed to have
been dead he kind of refers to himself
as a ghost and the idea here is what
does a ghost do
right well a ghost haunts and that's
kind of the crazy thing a ghost haunts
it lingers it travels from place to
place and it basically terrifies people
and so in the end despite having lost
everything he's actually
a more dangerous batman now than he was
before because the world believes he's
dead right the world believes he's gone
and if the world doesn't know you're
there
then you can effectively do pretty much
anything you want to and so on you know
instead of becoming like this extremely
violent character or anything like that
it's kind of him going back to business
as usual right he comes across a guy
who's basically being mugged in an
alley and he basically steps in and and
stops these guys right beats the crap
out of these guys but again
as we know when it comes to this this
version of gotham city that any and all
kind of fighting violence or any kind of
crime or anything like that
is immediately quelled by either the
peacemakers themselves or by their own
little drones or something like that but
gotham's always
under watch right it's always being
viewed by the authoritarian figures here
and so as soon as this fight breaks out
right within moments of this fight
happening suddenly it's
stop all movement right these drones are
right on the scene right they're right
there
now of course bruce wayne flees right he
gets the heck out of there as best he
can
but in that process he basically ends up
donning his batman suit and that's
what's kind of crazy here is because you
know once he's once he's kind of back
being batman himself word is inevitably
going to get around right word's going
to get around and he's told by order of
the magistrate you have to stop
and even when you have you know this
this peacemaker number one watching all
this go down he's watching all these
these scenarios right batman you know
run from place to place you know fleeing
from all these these different things
and he's getting him getting pictures of
him that kind of stuff and when he zooms
in he realizes this is actually batman
right batman's supposed to be dead
but this is actually batman batman's
basically back and that's where things
get a little wonky here because it may
be that that dc comics is at the moment
taking the kind of new 52 action comics
superman-esque approach here
where you have batman you know feature
state batman that takes place
in whatever this future is and that dc
features state
detective comics leads up to it it kind
of explains how we got to a point where
like
tim fox is back right or they could be
taking place at the same time we don't
really know right we don't have an
answer here we're one issue into each of
them we're gonna have to wait a little
while
it's a really good story i really like
it i'm gonna be honest i like this
better than i like batman
it's really really good but with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
to an end
if you are new here to comments explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what has happened what are we fighting
for
now we can't go back and we can't move